you were able to jump off the Roseann
ship right before it went down you got
all you got off when you realize wait a
minute this is going in a different
direction than I had thought but you
were you were a producer an executive
producer on the show consulting
consulting producer and a writer
so obviously you were involved and
obviously you knew Roseann were you
surprised by her tweets is she a
different person outside of Twitter
cause like you know for I've known what
she's been doing on Twitter and that
tweet I don't think was any good but it
didn't shock me that that came from
Roseann on Twitter but I also don't know
her outside of Twitter outside of
Twitter we got along great she yes she I
don't know who this Twitter person is
really
but the Roseann that I know personally
and how she presented herself it was not
this person who's like you know get
caught up in conspiracy theories and all
this but when we did last Comic Standing
we reached out to her to be a judge and
we had dinner with her and she was
really cool and was saying all the right
things hey I want to you know open this
up and to make it more diverse let's get
in your more women and people of color
and genders and I'm like okay cool great
great so that's that's the Roseann that
I worked with and even all rows even
doing this on the show Roseanne her
sitcom when we brought it back she
wanted to talk about stuff like how she
didn't her heard the original version of
the show so it was all good but but the
the Twitter has always been nuts ville
yeah I mean during last Comic Standing I
was worried I was like we gotta get her
off Twitter she's on kilis did you ever
say anything to her like Roseanne we
yeah you did yeah we said something well
actually talk to her daughter and I say
we I mean page her with my producing
partner we talked to her daughter and
and one time she said yeah I think it's
her boyfriend that's running the account
whatever and then I'm like one one day
we would show we're about to start and
rose I was like I'm tired
I've been up fighting the anti-semitism
all all night and we just kind of looked
at it looked at each other like oh I
hope you want when she heard that tweet
she said she didn't realize the woman
was black do you believe her or do you
think that was damaged controller do you
think that she really was just just
saying something like no I don't know I
think that was damage control okay she
said I didn't know the [ __ ] was black
because I'm like I thought she said I
thought the [ __ ] was white when that
when you saw that tweet did you leave or
did someone call you and tell you about
it or did you look at it go I have to I
can't be here someone sent me the the
the tweet I should a couple friends a
couple friends they text me and I looked
at it and then because I was actually
sending an email to Bruce Helford the
showrunner to let him know that I wasn't
I was going to miss the first two weeks
of the writers room because I booked the
gig on the other two this Comedy Central
show that just started up so and so I
pick up my phone to do that and I see
all these text messages I was like what
the hell and then when I saw the tweet I
was like Jesus did you know they were
gonna cancel her like you've been in the
business a lot they do you think she'll
survive this or she won't show me so
much money man it was you know it was
really successful see it was successful
it's like the highest numbers you know
they had in a while for a sitcom and and
I was like wow I can't be a part of it
out I'll let them figure it out but I'm
not gonna go back I didn't think they
should have fired her like if you didn't
want to work with her that's you know
again that's certainly your choice I
didn't think they should have fired her
though like cuz she came right out and
apologized she said hey look I'm sorry
and it seems like a lot of times now
when they have time they rethink it like
James Gunn they maybe they were old
tweek but then they brought him back
after a little while things cool off do
you think they reacted kind of quickly
when they got rid of her no no don't
think so
and I say that because of the just
because of it
if things were different in the country
right now if we weren't so divided then
maybe she could have pulled that out
with with some you know a a sit down big
teaching moment but there's no we don't
have any more no we don't have one more
Jim and Sam catch up with full episodes
and interviews from celebrity guests
anytime on demand using the Sirius XM
attic